you know even if a recipe seems like it
has a lot of steps or that it might be
hard if you just take your time enjoy
the process in the end you'll come out
with a great plate of food I'm gonna
show you how to make something that I
know you love and I grew up on spaghetti
and meatballs I like to add fresh onion
and garlic to my meatballs and marinara
because you're already doing all this
work to make dinner you might as well go
they just the extra step to make it
really special so the goal is to soften
these onions and garlic and get a little
bit of color after your onions are
cooked scoop out about 1/3 of a cup and
put it on the side to save it for later
for the meatballs to the cooked onions
add in your tomato paste caramelizing
the tomato paste until it's dark brown
in the pan and aromatic is called pink
sauce it's a very important step to
making sure that your marinara sauce it
tastes like it's homemade and not store
bought I love to use crushed tomatoes in
my marinara sauce because it will allow
it to be a nice smooth texture and
really coat all of your pasta but really
any type of canned tomato will work I
like to use dried herbs when I start my
sauce so that they flavor the marinara
as it cooks for a long time if you want
to use fresh herbs save them to the end
of the cooking process so that their
flavor stays intact put a lid on it and
let it simmer for at least 30 minutes
you can go for as long as you want there
are thousands of ways to make meatballs
but for me what makes mine so special is
that I have a secret ingredient ricotta
cheese ricotta is just the perfect
mixture of moisture protein and fat that
will help hold the meatballs together
and make the meatballs tender and juicy
use your fingers you know nature's tools
they work the best you can make large
meatballs tiny meatballs I like mine to
be golf-ball-sized don't feel bad if one
meatball isn't perfect as long as their
majority of the same size and shape
you're good to go and I took them in the
oven at a high temperature for a short
period of time that way your meatballs
have a tender inside can brown all the
way around while you're cooking them the
last step you want to do is clicking
your pasta use a generous pinch of salt
to make sure that your water is salty
briny like the ocean we don't want bland
pasta shimmy it
so it gets Luffy and Goofy you know let
it cook for about seven to ten minutes
until the pasta is al dente now al dente
is this another Italian word that means
to the tooth just undercooked enough
where it has a slight chew but is still
tended the best way to tell that your
pasta is perfectly cooked is just to
taste it yeah see it perfect
when draining your pasta to put it
immediately into your pasta sauce stir
it around so that the wonderfully
simmered sauce covers every single piece
of pasta it's a perfect marriage of
flavors spaghetti and meatballs is just
a classic Italian American dish it's a
recipe that I come back to time and time
again try it at home make it your own
have fun with it and you'll become a
master at spaghetti in no time
[Music]